I guess I keeping with the title on the
on the schedule it's a surprise talk
what I really wanted to sorry so this is
the first talk I've been given I'm
giving in a pretty long time in large
part because I had a baby and I realized
standing in front of you right now I
should probably put pictures of my baby
in the slides did not do that
great apologies but so it's my first
talk in a while and that has given me
some time to reflect on on some things
and so the the talk was called surprise
talk and I asked a few times the the
people who run this conference like what
do you want me to talk about and they
said like really whatever you want to
want to talk about and of course that
indeed gave me a lot of time to reflect
on what I should talk about usually it
helps to have some starting point as DHH
says constraints are liberating but
something happened this week that
actually got me thinking so tom tweeted
that he wrote this post asking Google
for better engagement with web
frameworks in 2016 and this week they
delivered on my entire wish list I'm
truly over the moon and Benedict tweeted
for those of you who haven't checked out
the dev summit keynote by multi-and and
nicole frameworks are considered
first-class citizens now which maybe
would be surprised everyone in this room
who probably uses frameworks like what
does it mean that they're not
first-class citizens that seems like a
surprising piece of news and there will
not be close collaboration between web
platform of frameworks how cool is that
and so I realized thinking about like
how do you explain what it means that
frameworks are now for the first time
considered first-class citizens
according to chrome what does that mean
I got me thinking about like what my
personal journey was in getting involved
in web standards and I want to start
with a disclaimer there's like a large
number of people who were involved in a
lot of this story that I'm about to tell
you and I could have spent the entire
time giving credit and thanking a lot of
people who were part of all those part
of all those moments unfortunately I
only have 25 minutes and I really know
my own like my own anecdotes better than
everyone else
so I apologize up front for the fact
that this is gonna end up kind of being
myopic from my own perspective but
hopefully my perspective is helpful or
useful in some way so I started
programming in 2005 which was I guess
pretty late and I was I was just being
up I was an open source person pretty
early and didn't really get involved in
any kind of like standards work or any
like very serious open source work until
like 2008 or 2009 when I ended up
getting on the rails core team by
building a competitor to rails having it
be successful and then us getting
together and singing Kumbaya and merging
the two things together so I was pretty
busy up until that point like trying to
figure out how open-source worked and
for some reason like largely because
jQuery didn't have good Doc's I also
ended up being on the jQuery core team
around the same time period so in
retrospect that was a pretty early time
in my career to be on both of the core
teams but it's just where I was at at
the time and so I was kind of pretty
aware of how open-source worked how web
developers did use things like jQuery
and Rails but pretty unaware of how like
the wider programming ecosystem worked
and I started thinking because I've been
working on jQuery and I've been working
on rails and you know if you're working
on jQuery you like interact with the Dom
a lot if you working on Rails you
interact with like the HTML and the and
the HTTP spec a lot and occasionally I
would go into a spec to try to figure
out like what is it talking about and I
would it would be like really hard to
understand what's happening and so I
asked myself like why why is it so hard
like why is it that if I want to
understand something it's really hard to
understand and I started asking around
like other people in web standards like
hey why like what's so hard and they
said well why not like we are very
enthusiastic to hear your feedback why
don't you give us some feedback so I
took a look at web IDL which if anybody
is aware of probably not the best place
to have started but as I said in my
this is my really my first standards
mailing list post ever I said at the
urging of some folks because people
claim they really want my feedback I've
poked around and I have some feedback
and really my first post ever was like
I'm finding it difficult to understand
like I don't understand how to how to
use it and I think there are other
people in the world who are not me who
also have that same problem and the
response that I got back in 2009 was
it's a word I said don't we agree that
it's a worthy goal to actually have
aspect that people can understand and
the response I got was it's a worthy
goal but it won't be possible to make it
so everyone who finds it so that
everyone finds it easy and quick to
understand the current syntax is not
familiar to only to implementers but
basically anybody who's already doing
specs already understands it so like
sorry you're out of luck so sort of what
I took away from that conversation in
2009 is like specs are for implementers
and they're for specs what they should
do is prioritize being understood by
people who already understand specs
unfortunately this is a bit of a
circular problem it will mean that
people can stick around for a long time
and they will continue to elevate
themselves in the in the group of people
understand specs but nobody can get in
for the first time unless you're like a
dedicating a lot of time to it because
your implement or something and I
realized at the time that there's kind
of a structural problem here which is
that when the web creates a new feature
how does it get introduced in 2009 it
got introduced as a spec and they're
telling everybody like hey you know it
would be great it would be great if
everybody all the web developers gave us
feedback about these specs but then they
also tell you oh but the spec is not for
you you're not supposed to read specs
and we're not even really interested in
making it easier for you to understand
so basically my my summary again at the
time was basically if spec authors
reject the idea of making specs more
accessible to web developers and they
also require new feedback in terms of
specs then we're just cut out of the
process and sort of how I felt about
that in 2009 was like that like it's not
fair and then like maybe little
righteously angry little like this is
really not fair
but I think at the end of the day in
2009 I was like a programmer for four
years
I got enthusiastic idea in the first
place like you should go in and give us
feedback I gave some feedback I was
basically told this whole process is not
really for you so I kind of just like
went away for a bit and I would say that
I it was like oh well I actually do know
how to make rails and jQuery so like
I'll just work on that and I continued
to do that for a little while
another thing that sort of happened at
the same time that was given like a
little bit after that which gave me some
perspective was that John Resig who I
looked up to him was like clearly not a
new programmer at the time who created
jQuery was like oh it's you know would
be great it would really be great if the
Dom was as good as jQuery and there's
just no reason why that couldn't be the
case so he wrote a proposal which was
the Dom node list API that was if you
look at the date on this it says eight
years ago and many parts of this are
still not implemented or even in
proposal form and basically me watching
John not really succeed at getting the
spanish process to take this proposal
seriously which if you look at it says
you can run the test suite it has a
thousand plus tests right so like
clearly he had done like really the
maximum amount of work that you could
possibly imagine to propose and it
wasn't really working so I was like
starting to feel like there's the
structural problem might be like pretty
serious it's not just me it's not just
I'm a new programmer but there might be
some serious structural issues and like
as I sort of wrapped up working on rails
3 and like poked my head back up again
and like felt like well there's still
not a ton of people involved in web
specs like I kind of like my takeaway
the first time was it's really unfair
but like maybe I'm just overwrought
ating maybe it's like a personal thing I
eat maybe I'm making people upset or
maybe I'm just too green I'm too much of
a noob but like I came back and like oh
it seems like people are claiming that
they're very enthusiastic about it so
probably now that people claim they're
very enthusiastic if I wait a little
while people will actually get involved
but what ended up happening was I waited
a few years finished up my other project
and notice that there still nobody
really involved in web specs
and I should say there are there are a
handful of people who were very involved
I think leav Errol is an example
somebody who I look up to a lot and was
like involved very early and these are
people who basically put up with an
extreme amount of frustration in order
to to participate and I'm not meaning to
take away from their participation I'm
just meaning to say that there weren't a
ton of people involved at the time so
I'm like thinking about this and chrome
actually came out around the same time
right so before chrome there was like
Firefox and ie ie had no standards
Firefox had this like kind of lumbering
old standards participation process and
like kind of a lumbering old codebase
and chrome came out and like looked like
there was some enthusiasm for maybe
doing things differently than in the
past in particular like Paul Irish who
was kind of like a enthusiastic
developer evangelist before he joined
Google joined Google and became
enthusiastic developer evangelist at
Google and like Paul and I were both on
the jQuery team and we talked a lot
about like what can we do about this
like this problem seems bad it seems
like something we should do about it
like what can we do about it
and the first thing we said is like well
maybe if we like DDoS the spanish
process with a lot of feedback maybe
they will notice that there is more
feedback than they thought because one
of the things that people said at the
time was there just aren't that many
people who are like really capable of
understanding enough to give good
feedback they would say like oh you guys
are just not really capable of this so
we said well maybe we could just like
show empirically that that's not true
so I tweeted this thing that said like
what is the one browser bug you could
fix know what is the one browser bug you
could fix or feature you can add
significantly to improve what you can
build on the web and basically the idea
was they like the browser vendors and
spec authors their perspective at the
time was like you need to understand
very very elaborate things in order to
give feedback but actually this question
is probably the right question to ask if
you want to figure out what to do so let
me ask that question and Paul wrote a
blog post right afterwards
the feedback end you can see him we got
a great response 230 plus responses and
I was pretty shocked actually at the
time this is like 2009 I don't even know
how many people were on Twitter at the
time or 2011 but that was like a lot of
responses to get and I embedded an
iframe here because I couldn't think of
a better way of giving a sense of the
amount of responses that we got but
there were a lot of responses that were
actually pretty good it's actually a
good list to go back to now because I'll
surprising amount of this is not done
I'm still scrolling so anyway we I like
I like this one is this so we were
basically like maybe we can like
illustrate directly that there is a huge
amount of enthusiasm for things that are
just being ignored because basically the
idea that people can't get feedback was
resulting in a lack of representation
from of web developers which was
resulting in web developer interest just
not being that considered so I we did
that and like people noticed and I me
and Paul were like well we just we
really need to show up and actually
start like banging the gong but we had
this problem the problem that I said
before which is that if fundamentally if
spec authors are like you were not
willing to make specs more accessible to
web developers and we think that's
actually a bug it's like a non non goal
on the other hand all this all the specs
are coming out as specs all the proposed
are coming out of specs we're cut out it
actually seems like structurally there's
a problem so the good news about this is
that thinking back on this like in 2011
I realized that chrome really changed
things among other things like standards
bodies even though they hadn't really
grappled with the consequences of the
problem were like very convinced that
they wanted more developer involvement
and they were still repeating like
developers aren't don't have time for
this kind of grunt work or like people
aren't capable or whatever but
ultimately if you ask them people were
like very enthusiastic about the idea of
getting more help and also another
subtle thing that happened was that the
chrome
team brought in a lot of ex web
developers so people like like Alex
Russell who worked on dojo was now like
a person working on the C++ part of
Chrome so and that there were a bunch of
people doing that so there was
definitely a sense in which there was a
little bit of representation on the
chrome team mostly of people who used to
be web developers but there were you
still like remember something about it
and there was more motivation to do
something so kind of looked at it and I
was like well I guess it's time to crash
the gates basically we were probably a
little over enthusiastic about what we
could do but I think we we felt like
basically the time is now like we did
this huge survey there's like a
surprising amount of things that people
want done that aren't getting done like
we should try to do something about it
and the first thing that we did was we
joined tc39 so at the time there were
zero people on Tizen 39 who worked on
who brought javascript or web software
for a living it was either like I would
say academics or theoreticians or
implementers of web browsers but zero
web developers on tc39 at all and today
that's not true and I'll talk about that
as I go on but at the time like one of
the reasons that nobody was joining was
that there was a sense like oh you have
to pay to join tc39 so like how can you
join obviously I don't have the money to
join a pay-for-play organization and
turns out that if you look at the rules
of tc39 not-for-profit organizations are
allowed to join for no fee and the
jQuery foundation which was the group
that Paul and I were involved in at the
time trying to do something about this
was a registered nonprofit so we were
able to join and we were able to become
members now I think ACMA immediately was
like oh that seems like a very big
loophole but I think ultimately nobody
wanted to say like jQuery is not allowed
to be on tc39 like we followed the rules
and I think that was more or less good
enough for for them and I think that
basically one of the takeaways I had was
like really pay attention to when people
say you can't do that because XYZ you
can't join TZ
because it will be too expensive like
like really investigate whether that's
true
and after joining T's 39 and becoming I
joined with Rick Waldron we became the
first two people who were web developers
of Tizen 39 I ran with a few people to
reform the w3c tag which is like the
steering committee I guess of w3c and
like I said a bunch of stuff it's like
probably cool blog posts to still read
at some point I made jokes about RFC's
but and and after running we won so for
four people ran on the idea of actually
getting more involvement about the
regular day-to-day so tc39 had problems
but the w3c at the time was full of
people who thought that the web the job
of a web standards body was the Semantic
Web which has nothing to do with the web
as we in this room understand it so
there was a big project there of like
resuscitating the w3c s core
architectural ideas around web
architecture and not around semantic web
architecture which only is the same
thing only in name only and like one of
the things I noticed when we joined was
like the tags phil was using CVS at the
time not not SPN like some of us might
remember hats they were literally using
CVS so I had to get like a CVS
accountant whatever and one of the first
things that we did was like just put the
tag on github and like you'd be
surprised at how controversial that was
but it was actually a big deal because
it may amend that there was a way that
people understood how to participate in
the process like get up issues and pull
requests that people found familiar that
was now how you also interacted with
what was frankly a pretty stodgy
organization that had nothing to do with
your needs right but if the only way to
participate before was like mailing
lists and CVS like good luck but if you
can file issues that helps but there was
still this problem so sort of the idea
was like we need to we need first we
need to have representation so like we
can if we want to reform any of the
structural problems we actually need to
be there and like in the place where
you're supposed to be to
we make the proposals but there was
still this issue of like functionally
this is not a rule anywhere but
functionally the way the web standards
feedback loop worked functionally cut
out web developers and I realized that
because of them the moment that we that
that was in we were able to we were able
to really change how we thought about it
and I think if you think about it today
that problem doesn't exist anymore and
one of the big watershed moments was I
decided to reach out to all the people
involved in web standards who shared
basically a view of this problem and I
wrote this extensive web manifesto which
was then signed by a lot of people which
I'll show in a second but the key thing
that the extensible web manifesto said
was it's actually pretty bold it says we
want to change our web standards
committees create and prioritize new
features and importantly we want to
tighten the feedback loop between
editors and web standards and web
developers so that if you if you ever
heard of this like it's probably worth
going back and reading but the key thing
was we said we have a manifesto that
says that we need to fix the structural
problem and like a cool thing about it
was a lot of people signed it so again
because the moment was ripe for getting
agreement on something a lot of people
signed something that fundamentally said
that the old structural problem was not
okay anymore so that that happened in
like 2013 and I could spend like another
hours talking about all the things that
happen in between because because
frankly once we got to a point where
there was a more appropriate feedback
loop I wouldn't say it was perfect by
any means but there was like web
developers are structurally allowed to
be in the conversation a lot of the next
like the story of the next five years is
like doing work like actually doing work
and I think things like service worker
actually landed and that like the chrome
team gets a lot of credit for that
but so do all the web developers who
push back against app cache not working
so well and really pushing hard on on a
new feature and like helping people who
are motivated to do it
convince their colleagues right so a lot
of the work of the next few years it's
really just like doing work but I wanted
so I'm gonna sort of skip ahead like
boring doing work part and just talk
about like by the by the by the numbers
basically so first of all I want to say
we thought a lot of work to do like
sorry in part in part because just like
there's a lot always a lot more to do
but and also in part because the problem
of under-representation and tech is not
limited to web developers there's a lot
of groups that are underrepresented and
the benefits that we got from include
increasing the number of web developers
in standards bodies is are also the same
as the benefits that you get from
increasing participation of any
underrepresented group for all the
reasons that the previous talk was
talking about so there's still a lot of
work to just actually continue to
increase representation in standards and
it and I don't want to sugarcoat where
we're at so I want to say that but
overall the sentiment that we have right
now is much healthier and part of what
that means is that we now try very hard
at least in tc39 to co-locate our
meetings with community events like J's
coffee you so that we can hold things
like this this what was this thing
called it was called a panel so we can
hold panels and like basically everyone
at J's coffee you got to ask committee
members what they thought about various
in-flight features and like the general
process and the group of people on the
stage here are actually pretty
representative of tc39 and largely are
people doing day-to-day JavaScript work
and I think that's pretty great that I
also just need to call out if I'm gonna
call it anybody here computer computer
okay dan has been doing a huge amount of
work to try to just increase the amount
of feedback that tc39 gets so this is
like him giving a talk on like we want
your help to make the next guest but
really what this what has been about is
dan has been has poured a ton of time
into creating community groups so
there's an educator group a framework
group a transpiler group that is
basically just getting feedback from
groups of people that maybe don't have
time or money to join tc39
to travel but who have very useful
feedback and having regular meetings
where those groups of people can give
their feedback about proposals and
actually bring that feedback back to
tc39 doing more of that has been
invaluable I think that's kind of the
next frontier at least 42:39 is like
just making more of these not in the
committee groups of people just to get
feedback funnels working and remember
when I joined T's 39 in the first place
there were no web developers working on
tc39 there was the best we had was
people who used to be web developers or
on Tizen 39 but now today there are
JavaScript developers who work day to
day on JavaScript from big companies
like Google and Facebook for small
companies like the one I work at Cavalia
and boku there's people who represent
frameworks there's people who represent
libraries there's people who represent
compiled to JavaScript languages there's
people who represent transpilers like
Babel there's now node joined and p.m.
join right so now we have like it used
to be zero in 2011 and now in 20 in 2018
it's really a very very robust group of
people representing a whole bunch of
different parts of the ecosystem and it
just goes without saying that when you
have this many groups of people involved
the kinds of objections that people have
when they just don't have JavaScript
developers in the room just don't go
very far right so you could say you used
to be able to say like oh I don't know
if anybody uses function declarations or
whatever and now if you say like people
like there actually was an argument that
like oh we should just switch to like
some other thing because no one uses
that feature or like AMD is good enough
to nobody we don't need Center modules
or whatever and like these days
there's enough JavaScript developers
like frankly we we argue amongst each
other like we have so many people that
now like our now the the group of
JavaScript practitioners is we're
actually able to have debates amongst
ourselves without feeling like like
we're too small right so now there's
just a huge amount of JavaScript
developers representing a huge amount of
different interests on the committee and
I think this has been like really the
I'm very proud of this result going back
to the beginning of the story here
beginning of this talk so one thing that
was kind of sad that I skipped over in
between
2013 and 2018 is that browser developers
didn't always see web developers as
allies and part of the reason for that
is that as mobile took off and browser
vendors got squeezed for performance
browser vendors would go look at like
why is the verge calm very slow and
would say oh your javascript is terrible
and you're using this like terrible
framework with these terrible tools and
like if only everybody just hand wrote
everything by hand everything would be
better and like that is a thing that
people that is a thing that people would
say so Alex in 2016 who co-signed
extensible of manifesto and like points
this out in this thread basically says
like seriously folks it's time to throw
out your frameworks and see how fast the
browser can be right and basically not -
not to say anything about Alex but there
was definitely even though we like got
agreement across a lot of people about
the extensible web manifesto what
started like there was a period of time
where there was just not a very strong
alliance between browser vendors and web
developers especially framework
developers again I think a big part of
that had to do with mobile squeezing
browser vendors for performance they're
hearing about it from people who say why
is your browser so slow and they're
trying to figure out how to explain it
and so that's why this thing that
happened this week was so important so
Nicole got up on stage and said it's not
that you should throw out your framework
framework sometimes make apps lower but
they're also our best hope to make them
faster and multiple who made amp said
that's a bold statement and she said yes
that is a bold statement but the I think
the point is we're finally coming to the
end of the story here where we're
finally coming back to us actually all
being in it together which I think was
we had it for a moment in 2013 and I
think we've kind of gone around the
block a little so another thing just to
just to give them credit is they're now
including frameworks like the popular
frameworks in the intent to implement
process so the intent to implement
process is like how chrome announces
like we're gonna implement this feature
that is a standard and like people can
come in and be like oh that would be
really hard to implement or like that
would require a Ryoka texture of the
entire blah blah blah system so sorry
they're basically now involving frame
authors like myself in the process of
like deciding what to do and I should be
clear like chrome is not the web and
there already is a standard process that
web developers are already involved in
like because of all the work that people
have done so this is not like chrome
doesn't get to involve web developers
but there was a problem which is that at
the end of the day browser vendors have
a lot of control over what goes what
happens in the process because they're
the ones who get to ship so a big
browser saying like we're involving
regular web developers in the decisions
about shipping things really makes a big
difference in terms of like where the
leverage comes from in this in the
standards process so that's really
exciting and in general like that the
ballpoint 3 is like a very vague thrinng
thing but in general chrome has spent a
lot of effort in the past year more or
less of really involving web developers
more in their own process so like I said
I could I could give a whole talk on
like how to get involved but I'll give
you like my quick hits here so first of
all like if you're interested in doing
technical work and you want to do
something with standards like go ask
your favorite framework author like hey
you probably have standards goals like
what could I help with and there's
actually a lot of stuff like as much as
I made fun of the testing thing before
you could write tests you can do a whole
bunch of stuff so I'm just delegating to
your yes I see I'm almost out of time I
have like three slides left this thing
is the thing a lot of people don't know
about so this is like a really
well-organized
dashboard that tells you like where
every single tc39 proposal is by stage
each one of them links to a tc39 links
or repository which has regular issues
and regular pull requests and does
things the usual github way and it tells
you like what the progress is so
definitely check this out if you're like
I wonder what the status of that feature
is or how can I help move this feature
over the finish line you can also try
features out with Babel I put a star
there because there are some like ornery
tc39 members who get angry when you say
like oh people try it out with Babel and
now we shouldn't do something different
because people liked it I think
increasingly those people are not
winning but
there is definitely a sense that like we
shouldn't feel beholden to whatever
happened to ship in Babel and I think
like as a user trying to things out in
Babel you should realize that like I
said it's a big deal that things aren't
get out like just go to like if you're
wanting to talk about decorators or
optional chaining or pipeline or
whatever just go to the go to the repo
look for an issue that you're interested
in open an issue help write explain or
as facts whatever people really love the
help and I just want to close by with
the part of the extensive web manifesto
this is what the extensible web
manifesto closed with and what I
basically said was you know the open web
is seen as always being behind the
walled garden competitors like open web
is seen as being worse than iOS or worse
than Android and there's a real good
reason why that's not true which is that
Android and iOS comes down from a
mountain every year and they hand you
the things that their developers came up
with and so the feedback loop is really
slow and when things are working well on
the web we have a path for good ideas
from web developers to become a part of
the infrastructure of the web and what I
said in the extensive web manifesto that
got so many so many signatures is we
have to enable web developers to build
the future of the web and I think more
than ever now that's possible and I so I
would encourage everyone here to help
build a future of the web thank you very
much